hello everybody my name is Marc Marc all
right I'll hang back falling back oh I
look like a little micro machine care
I'm a yellow you got a little flower on
the back thank you
you should see me when I burst like you
explode into flowers no watch do you see
that you see did you see oh I see you
upside down look at me now look at me
whether the Hat flowers [ __ ] I almost
did that the wrong way
no just cuz there's less people to blame
our badness on oh you got flowers you
guys whoa that guy's got money guys good
job that did not go the way I wanted it
to no no no I missed it completely okay
it's gone
mr. Mahoney bags over I love doing flips
yeah I know that's what I was doing
instead of actually playing the game
good and helping my team I was just
doing a lot of faux no you helped you
helped actually that was good oh [ __ ] Oh
oh man
I'm getting nervous now yeah my god
people actually are relying on me I have
to like perform I got performance
anxiety no no all that never that is so
vascular you know right when you're
nervous is that what you want to sniff
my butthole we're so majestic Wow we
always laugh she told me you were going
pink I did I don't know I always pink I
like pink wait dink
Cranmer's I actually was rewatching Iron
Man 3 and I didn't realize like the
first time The Cranberries thing
happened was like when Jarvis got
screwed up after he went to the other
place it's like I just sometimes say the
wrong cranberry at the end of the recent
as I say the wrong cranberry that was
actually a thing for my urn Man 3 oh
cool it oh man it plays like piece
sounds when I do maybe my my little
burst there it's pretty freakin hearty
bread it is it's a very hippy dippy
peace and love and all that [ __ ] yeah
exactly
wait what are you are you anti laws are
you I am anti a love are you not fro
love you never heard how angry I get go
dude go binge out go Grimmjow go
Grimmjow underscore 87 you'll be super
famous soon you you don't you you
knocked me all the way I was gonna go
for it I didn't notice anyone else we
were playing the game whoa sorry
bonk we got that guy go ball yeah you're
gay
have you ever seen like professional
people play this game no are they good
oh god I guess that's a stupid question
ask about professional players No ow
how could you let that happen look at
this just stood around it what Ben Grimm
Joe look at this
Oh what an a-hole he probably didn't to
hit from that direction but he didn't
know that it was gonna help okay one off
we got this do we got this I'm not sure
that we do Punk
oh we can got this they might have an
afk oh yeah Tokyo real Tokyo is giving
me a little bit of a good
if you could change your wheels if you
could change your balls would you would
you not out well yes yes yes yes this is
going exactly according to plan
oh oh sweet [ __ ] sick [ __ ] oh I got in
the way probably no you didn't they just
[ __ ] it up I happen to do that a lot
with fur getting in the way of things I
don't make this you don't like this how
about a little bit of yes sure that's
not what I want out get that Merc
I'm trying oh there we go okay it's a
bunch of idiots shuttle I in a ball not
doing anything okay grimmjow is going
that's really nice
yes yes yes oh god oh god oh god yes
this is the most tame lame no I think
actually did a thing oh here we go here
we go here we go here we go yes oh no
god damn it again with the no tryharding
right now
me too so nervous my heart's going a
million miles an hour no no no no that
was that was all Grimmjow look at this
look at this [ __ ] I missed it then
Grimmjow like him oh no he tried you
messed him up
yeah you messed him up after okay we
just gotta go for this go go for the
goal come on the Go Go Go Go
[ __ ] missed dammit that was scary
those scary like losing 24 he's so bad
rock you and he got 500 cuz he sat in
goals okay alright okay that never
happened
okay I'm hanging back oh you're hanging
back too I love that when the game grabs
did their kings King yeah I think it's
someone talking in this game okay oh I
hit it back that's not good enough
though people are not gonna be proud no
well the game's not over yet so everyone
is missing my god
no one can hit this ball except for me I
was gonna follow Celtx Marco took my
credit I was gonna that was gonna be me
all right do i you're just trying to
come in and steal yes of course what
else can I do a barely I'm worse at this
game than I thought it is quite hard
Bernie you're supposed to switch between
cams all the time that guy yes morning
are you just I guess seeing where
everyone else is in relation to where
you are is probably a good idea yeah
like switch back from ball cam cuz it
can get confusing when it's underneath
you or something like that I hit that
the wrong way I'm an idiot go thank you
thank you thank you for saving my
stupidness alright you know what
I must switch I'm a switched to the
other cam just cuz I've been playing
with ball cam for a long time now
if we lose our claim another yes
everybody floating away
he's amazing I love him shut up I'm your
partner in this one I love you Mac
you're the best I don't believe you for
a second uh-huh I did I touched it real
good touching you that's not at all I'm
like yeah I got it I got somebody I
don't know Michael
I'm trying to do things everyone else is
getting in my way just a stupid rap
whoa holy crap three people just
exploded people are just exploding
randomly yay oh you fell I'm so close oh
you just happen to fail everybody
straining I'm doing fine if everyone
else wasn't here it'd be great
oh [ __ ] whoa
that's so lucky shut up
I was skill I was it turns out I was the
skill go go nice nice nice oh man I
chest won't be so hard if you were here
right now
oh man me too many times repeatedly with
our manly pecs
exactly yeah oh yeah plus one place X
plus one biceps show off your biceps to
the camera right now the game seriously
get it up go Papa oh I was in the right
space I I moved out I was in the right
headspace thing also I had a hand in
that bad that happened amen no I was
coming in he hit it then I didn't know
that was you that was all you those all
you reach out there I'm sorry guys I let
you down you let down the one goal
really what it's for one oh no no no no
don't go they have is one I scored for
them fun yes exactly
if you're terrible I have brought shame
timely you did if we lose this game
because of you I will never forgive you
I will cancel my trip to Ireland to come
visit you but not anymore brother you
ain't getting none of this Hagan ah
[ __ ] sake bill Cole blade 76 bilko
blade what was wrong with the first 75 I
don't know maybe they were taken because
bilko blade is such a cool name wait is
he born in 76
is he an old player Oh is he an old
layer I was gonna help I was gonna help
I was right
god I'm
helping this to just go ahead and play
with Celtic Marco then [ __ ] Mary oh
yeah will you do that brother brother I
could I could also call it oh yeah
brother like you call the other one bro
job it's gonna throw job
yeah click baby you know yeah I could
call it rocket-powered bro job wow I am
having it out with this guy we are we
are having a moment here we're having a
tender loving moment how do you like
this now huh I got I got veyts n84 he's
going down I took I took here this guy
you did
I got another body I want a Viking
helmet oh those fun god this games too
fun yes and apparently you're way better
than me than me em you are good or deny
you much good er and smart him than me
be I do more goodly yeah also thank you
for watching us that was everything
what's that do it thanks everybody
thanks Jack for playing if you guys want
more like will always this games to fun
games to play ok so thanks again
everybody thanks jack check out Jack's
channel description below now as always
we'll see
that was my strategy